in a heavily armed convoy the man
accused of being the sole survivor of
the isis attackers who brought carnage
to paris was sped through the streets
from france's highest category prison
security was intense ahead of salah
abdassalam's arrival at court police
divers searching the banks of the river
sen outside
inside the complex loved ones of those
killed by the terrorists were amongst
the hundreds waiting anxiously wondering
if the key defendant would cooperate
even speak at the start of the hearing
he did in the most provocative of
fashions asked what his job was
abdassalam told the court i gave up any
profession to become an islamic state
soldier later in the day removing his
mask and shouting that he and the other
defendants were being treated like dogs
provoking an angry response from
survivors and families present
pierre alexis simona is representing the
relatives of a 34 year old man killed at
the bataclan concert hall and says this
is the start of what will be a painful
process
i think it's extremely tough for them
emotionally speaking but they're also
mostly very
voluntary they're being very brave about
it because they know that this is uh
necessary for their rebuilding process
after this very traumatic event
abdassalam seen here wandering through
the streets of brussels a year before
the attacks is one of 20 men accused of
involvement in the mass shootings and
bombings in paris in november 2015. 130
people were killed and hundreds more
injured it's taken six years to bring
the alleged terrorists to court
this trial is of course about
establishing the guilt or innocence of
the defendants but it will ask wider
questions about why young men like salah
abdassalam a french citizen became
radicalised and how at a time of
heightened security in france isis was
able to plan and carry out the attacks
but what many relatives of those killed
and survivors hoped for is a full
account from abdassalam himself his role
his motivation in committing such
violence all the indications from the
first day are that he will not cooperate
easily michelle clifford sky news paris